Hong Kong is a maze of stores their shop
filed on top of shop filed on top of
shop you help me sort through all of
this is this guy Sam great to see you hi
Betty welcome to Hong Kong thank you
show me would love to wait that's my
favorite sport Hong Kong's Causeway Bay
is where you come to shop if money's no
object Burberry Cartier Rolex
they're all here and the landlords
collect some of the highest rents in the
world so that we are in front of the
store that just sold for 23 million US
dollars
is that a record it is I think it's the
most expensive store per square foot in
the world today how much would this get
all right it's currently on the market
for about 400,000 Hong Kong a month so
this store has to make ten thousand US
dollars a day yes and when the lease is
up stores can expect to pay a lot more
or leave Russell Street has transformed
in the last two to three years going
from more mass-market orientated stores
such as Levi's and McDonald's etc
now the street is dotted with high
fashion stores and jewelry shops Russell
Street topped New York's Fifth Avenue as
the most expensive in the world but
paying sky-high rent is no problem for
the luxury retailers here sales in Hong
Kong are very very strong you're saying
for instance Louie Vuitton had six
freestanding stores in Hong Kong we
could be talking about three four five
six seven hundred million dollars
altogether to be generated just right
here in the city combined market I would
not be surprised opposing the types of
numbers one do they want to come here as
a brand it's it's a great place for me